(piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal.
Naked.
Large brain.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans
like you.
(electronic music)
(upbeat, bubbly music)
- So yes, I'm going to talk you primarily,
I'm going to start with a
discussion about what fear is
because my views on this have
crystallized in recent years.
And if you know anything about what I do,
you probably don't really know what I do
because it's been misrepresented
quite a bit over the years.
So, fear, I think most of us will agree,
is an awareness that there's
a threat to well-being
that's present or eminent.
And this can be in the form
of these kinds of biological
or social cues that have the
potential to cause us harm.
And when we encounter these
kinds of threatening events
a lot of things happen
in our brains and bodies
that some of them are
recognizable by others,
and that's how we judge someone else
as being fearful or anxious,
but others are more internal
and we can only judge
in ourselves in terms
of body responses.
Of course we can measure these objectively
if we hook a person up to
some sort of physiological recording.
But the most important part
of fear is the internal
awareness that you're in danger.
Now, the traditional view
of how this comes about,
and I'm partly responsible for this,
is that this part of the
brain called the amygdala,
which you heard about a bit earlier,
is a fear center.
That is a view that is
widely cast in the culture
and the scientific circles as well.
The idea is that the
threat in the outside world
is processed by sensory systems
that reaches the amygdala,
it arouses the state of fear
and fear causes these behavioral
and physiological responses.
Now, when I talked about fear
as being involved in the amygdala,
which I've done for almost 30 years now,
the idea was that what
the amygdala was doing
was processing implicitly,
or non-consciously, threats
and that the conscious
experience of fear was coming
about through a different mechanism
which I proposed was in the neocortex
and I'll describe that in a bit later.
But what got carried forth
in the scientific and lay culture is that
I said that fear is in the amygdala.
And I think that this is wrong.
And that's what I want to
help clarify as we move forward today.
So, what's wrong with the idea?
Well the idea is based on
two kinds of observations,
one is that when a person or an animal
has some problem with their amygdala
they no longer respond to
threats in the way that
you can measure,
like behaviorally or physiologically.
And secondly, when an animal or human is
exposed to a threat,
activity increases in the amygdala.
So these two things kind of suggest
that the amygdala's processing threats
and that has led to the
conclusion that the amygdala
is the source of fear.
But that I think is a leap
that's too far to make.
So, why is that a leap that's too far?
Well behavioral and
physiological responses
don't always correlate with subjectively
reported experiences of fear.
Medications that are used to treat fear
or an anxiety
are more likely to change
behavioral responses
like avoidance or timidity
and physiological responses
like hyperarousal,
than the subjective feeling of fear.
And as a result of point two, there,
all the major drug
companies are pulling out
of the anti-fear,
anti-anxiety medication business
because they view the results
of efforts to develop new
and better treatments as a failure.
They don't consider a
reduction in behavior
and physiology a success
because the patient doesn't feel
less fearful or anxious.
So, the therapist is disappointed,
the patient is disappointed,
and the drug companies are disappointed.
So, number three,
threats elicit amygdala activity
and behavioral and physiological responses
in the absence of subjective awareness
that the stimulus exist.
As in, Nick Humphrey's famous
blind sight situations,
in human rather than monkeys though.
And without any feeling of fear.
So, this could be done
through studies of blind sight
but also through studies
of so-called subliminal
presentations of stimuli.
Where stimuli are presented very briefly
or masked by some other kind of stimulus.
The stimulus is present.
It's a threat.
The person doesn't feel fear
and yet the amygdala is still activated
and the responses are still expressed.
Fear is not the cause of those responses.
And finally, in the damage
to the amygdala in a human
eliminates the behavioral
and physiological responses
but not subjective feelings of fear.
So, all of this, to me,
suggests that fear is not
coming out of the amygdala
but some place else.
So, I will put an X through
this fear circuit view
and I first want to redefine
what the amygdala does.
I think one way to describe it that is
semantically more neutral
and doesn't imply that fear is emerging,
bubbling up out of the amygdala,
is to simply call it a
defensive survival circuit.
Every animal has to detect
and respond to danger,
as we heard about birds
being able to detect
and respond to danger.
And I was happy to hear that
fear didn't come up there.
It was described as responses
to danger and threat.
So every animal,
from a worm to a human,
has to be able to detect
and respond to danger
in order to stay alive.
Even bacterial cells have to
detect and respond to danger.
So the detecting, responding to danger
has nothing to do with psychology.
It's there to keep the organism alive.
And if you have some kind of psychology
because of the kind of brain you have
then you become aware
that you're in danger
and you experience fear.
So, threats activate the
defensive survival circuit
but that non-consciously
controls defensive responses
and humans have inherited this
defensive survival circuit from animals
but not the conscious experience of fear.
So if the amygdala's
not the source of fear,
how does it come about?
I have to say it comes about
like any other conscious experience.
And we might argue about
how that comes about.
And there are some experts in the room
that may not agree with me
but my own position is that
once we understand consciousness,
we'll get an understanding
of emotions for free.
(crowd laughs)
So my shot at it is something like this.
Which is an idea that really started
when I was doing split
brain work in the 1970's
as a graduate student.
And I won't go into that
but the idea is that,
and I proposed this model in 1984
before I did any research on fear itself,
but the basic idea is that
threat comes into the brain
and it's processed through
different kinds of channels.
There are connections from sensory systems
into this defensive survival
circuit that control
these behavioral and
physiological responses
and then to cortical areas,
where you have processes like attention
and working memory that
can put things together
and hold them in mind.
And one of the things that can be added
into working memory is the fact that
this defensive survival circuit is active
and that you're getting feedback
from the body and so forth,
and all this kind of coalesces in the mind
to make fear a cognitive event.
Not an innate feeling inherited
from animal ancestors.
So, I'm not saying that animals have
no conscious experiences,
no subjective experiences
of fear or anxiety,
or anything like that,
but if they do they're
probably very different
from the kinds of experiences we have.
So why is this kind of theory needed?
For one reason,
fear doesn't have an exclusive
contract with the amygdala,
which is generally thought to be
a kind of predatory defense system.
We can be afraid,
we can have fear,
from starvation,
dehydration,
hypothermia,
reproductive isolation,
each of which depends on
other survival circuits.
So, the key is not that
the amygdala is activated
but that you have some kind of activity
that threatens your existence,
or potentially causes you harm.
So, what we feel depends on
what kinds of signals are being
processed in working memory,
Including signals from survival circuits
but other signals as well.
So rather than having a
kind of subcortical circuit,
one for each kind of basic emotion,
I purpose that the cortical cognitive,
high-order, representation
of information accounts for emotional
and non-emotional experiences
in one kind of basic system.
And I won't have time
to go into any of the
evidence for all of this right now
but I'd like to make it--
analogize it by explaining
how you make soup.
Which you all know.
You take water, onions, garlic, carrots,
all kinds of ingredients,
put them into the pot,
and none of these are soup ingredients.
They're things that exist in nature that,
when combined in a certain way,
make soup.
And I think emotions
are like this as well.
We have lots of things in our brain
that are there for various reasons,
like sensory processing,
survival circuits,
brain arousal,
body feedback,
attention,
semantic memory,
episodic memory,
implicit fear schema,
monitoring,
awareness that you are in danger,
interpretation.
Most of these have nothing
to do with fear or emotion.
They're simply things that exist
to allow you to accomplish other goals.
So, when you put them
together in a particular way,
fear is what results.
Now, this kind of re-schematizes all this.
On the left side of the diagram,
we have things that would be contributing
to regular old conscious experience,
non-emotional states.
And on the right side,
there are ingredients
that begin to tilt it
into a kind of emotional direction.
And you can see the survival
circuit multiplicity there
that can generate activity
that will help tilt it
in one way or the other.
There are a couple of important things
on this I want to point out.
On the two sides of the
vertical line there,
Self schema and emotion schema.
I think these are both very important.
Unless you have an
awareness that the danger
is happening to you,
there's no fear or any
other kind of emotion.
In order to be emotional,
you have to realize that it's you
that is experiencing the situation.
A threat might cause you
to respond in a certain way
but if you don't know that
it's happening to you,
you're not afraid.
Now, you might say
well, I can be afraid or
worried about my children
if I see them in danger
but your children are in
effect part of who you are.
As are the, William James says,
a man's yacht is part of who he is.
(crowd laughs)
I would be very unhappy
if I lost my guitar
because it is such an
important part of who I am.
So, I think self schema, very important.
But also, emotion schema.
As the child begins to grow up
and experience the world
and come across dangerous situations,
they're told what danger is,
they may experience danger themselves,
they observe it on TV and in movies,
They build up these
schemas about danger is
and when fear occurs.
So that, when you you
have these kinds of schema
it's very easy to pattern
complete the entire
representation of what
fear is with just a few
or maybe even one element.
If a threat is present,
you're probably moving toward
a cognitive pattern completion
that the situation is one in
which you are feeling fear.
Add in the fact that
escape is not possible
and that your heart is
beating fast, and so forth,
and bingo.
You've got the whole thing close up.
So the idea that emotions are
cognitively assembled states
made by the information
available in working memory
is related to Levi Strauss's
notion of bricolage.
In french this means
to put things together,
items that happen to be available.
He emphasized the importance
of the individual,
the bricoleur,
and the social context in
the construction process.
Others note that maybe
persons, objects, contexts,
the sequence and fabric of everyday life
are the medium through which
emotions come into being,
a day to day kind of emotional bricolage.
In the brain,
working memory can be
thought of as the bricoleur,
and the content of emotional
consciousness as the bricolage.
So, if emotions are
cognitive events in circuits
that differ in significant ways in humans
and other animals,
including other primates,
than emotions we experience,
including emotions related
to death may be unique
and unparalleled in the animal kingdom.
Add language and culture
to the emotional equation
and the case strengthens.
So, animals may have
subjective experiences
but can't have the kinds
of experiences we have.
Or at least, that's how I think about it.
So, second part of my title is,
Is fear of death a fear?
Fear formally defined as
the awareness that a threat
to your well-being is present.
Anxiety is the expectation
of worry that your well-being
may be compromised in the future.
Many situations described as
fears are really anxieties.
But fear and anxiety are
really conjoined twins.
Even in a clear case of bodily threat,
fear quickly morphs into
worry about the future.
A snake at your feet causes you to freeze
and feel fear of bodily harm
but that's soon complimented,
if not overtaken by worries
about what will happen
if you are bitten.
Will you die?
Will you get to the
emergency room in time?
Will they have the antidote?
And so forth.
And death is always in the future,
so it's a worry or an
anxiety rather than a fear.
Fear and anxiety are products
of the same cortical system
in my theory.
But different subcortical circuits
are part of what makes
fear and anxiety different.
Specifically, subcortical
circuits underlying
the processing and control
of bodily responses
related to immediate or certain threats
versus future and uncertain
threats are different.
In the case of the
immediately present threat
the amygdala's very important.
In the case of a future threat,
an area called the bed nucleus
of the stria terminalis
is important.
Now, the bed nucleus
has become for anxiety,
what the amygdala is for fear.
It's been viewed as the source
of anxiety but it's not.
Like the amygdala,
the text then responds to threats.
In this case threats in the future.
Fear and anxiety are the
cognitive interpretation
that these things are happening.
So, what does it matter
what we call thees things?
First of all,
why does it matter what
we call fear and anxiety?
Why can't we just use one word
and maybe even just use
them interchangeably?
For one reason,
the problems that afflict people
that have these conditions
need to be treated differently
if the threat is a worry
about the future as opposed to
a kind of over sensitivity
to an immediately present stimulant.
But in the case of fear of death,
or anxiety about death,
the imprecision in scientific terminology,
while a constant problem,
it can easily be avoided by being
clearer about the language.
So in treating someone, say,
who is obsessed with death,
or in designing treatments
that might help people
who are at the end of life
and needing to not be
quite as anxious about it,
thinking about these things in terms
of what's going on in the brain
can actually be more constructive
than simply assuming that it
all happens in the same way.
And that's my two cents
about fear of death.
Thank you.
(crowd applauds)
(upbeat, bubbly music)